we break down the text that drives the
games we love here with game tech and
this time we're going to shed a little
light on some lighting techniques so how
can you make the bright lights in a game
pop-out more and make low-light areas
look more lifelike there's blue and HDR
rendering and we'll also get into the
recent surge of HDR display and as
always be sure to subscribe to our
channel here at GameSpot bloom increases
the luminosity of light sources and
objects that reflect light in a game
world tension is to make the scene look
more realistic closer to what we see in
the real world light will sleep through
windows and Suns will shine brighter the
widest parts are intensified almost
creating a sort of aura around these
surfaces however there are plenty of bad
examples of bloom there could very well
be an unnatural over saturation of light
or objects glowing in an off-putting way
it will be recognizable when surfaces
are reflective or shining when they
really shouldn't be The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt is one of the many games that
offers a bloom option and it's
implemented extremely well looking
directly at the Sun with bloom off is
like looking at a white fall with bloom
on it looks as if it's realistically
emitting lights that appropriately
cascades across the environment while
the quality of bloom will vary from game
to game
we would suggest turning it on if you
think it provides a richer more
believable visual experience if it's
distracting and over saturates the game
world you may want to go without it high
dynamic range or HDR is a little
different and it can be divided into two
different entities first HDR can be an
effects in a graphics engine that
creates a wider range in contrast so
darken areas are darker and brighter
areas are brightened this heightened
contrast affects the visuals when you're
in a dark room and step outside to a
brighter environment when this occurs in
real-time it simulates the ever-changing
exposure of light we experience in real
life and simulates the time it takes for
the human eye to adjust the tech demo
half-life 2 Lost Coast was the most
prominent early examples of HDR
rendering in game so I've essentially
showed off what the source engine was
capable of back in the day HDR is a
display technology is a little different
when cameras are shooting in HDR they're
typically taking multiple exposures to
highlight the dark and light
formation in a scene from their
processing and views to combine these
exposures into one picture for an image
that's more representative of how we
perceive light in color
HDR on TVs tries to represent colors in
a more realistic way but instead of
using image processing to combine
exposures together it simply uses a
panel that offers a much wider color
gamut compared to standard RGB TV but
why should you care about HDR in terms
of image qualities HDR increases the
contrast between bright pixels and dark
pixels over what traditional displays
offers this means the overall image will
look less gray or washed out colors will
look much more lush and vibrant for
instance on-screen fire effects will
look warmer and images will in general
have a little more pop and it's real
noticeable when you experience the
difference in a game while many HDR
displays feature a 4k resolution not all
4k displays will support HDR having said
that HDR pairs very well with 4k since
it makes good use of the greater pixel
density to create that richer more
dynamic image aside from an HDR display
you'll need an HDR capable device and
HDR content which developers need to
implement Microsoft's Xbox 1's and Xbox
one X supports HDR and Sony included HDR
support for the ps4 pro and provided an
HDR update for existing ps4 this was the
fifth in a series of PC graphics
settings explainers so do yourself a
favor and check out the other videos if
you haven't already now keep those
comments coming in because we're reading
them and if you found this helpful
give us a thumbs up subscribe to our
Channel you know the deal we'll see you
soon thanks for watching